I don't want to drink, you can't drink enough.
While you're at it, go clean up that area. He's
cute. Now I'll have another drink.
Cheers
[Music] I
totally forgot about him. Wait
a minute, stop. I do
n't have a firearm, so I'll do it right now.  Stop, leave me wondering
if you're listening. It's
over. It's the
technique Jingi-san summoned, so I'm
only targeting Jingi-san. It's
my
technique.
[Music] Let's do something. Even if you say something like
that, what should I do?
Hey, stop! I was born holding it.
Let go.  I understand, but I have to do something about it.
[Music] The
beginning of the world has been designated as the world's test. The
useless are without rights.
This is
named the beginning of the heavens and the earth.
YOU is named the mother of all things. I will make you a lost dog.
Go on the path.  Go home. It's
not
rust that came from my body, it's probably a spirit that came from my body. Drink
alcohol in moderation, a sacred treasure.